quand les grenouilles gros a fait du
beau temps à chaque fois qu'il ya les
mouettes qui parle au dessus cette ville
a régulièrement le lendemain il peut
pour le beau temps pour que les
hirondelles le volvo c'est le à la saint
médard
il pleut encore 40 jours plus tard à
moins que saint barnabé lui coupe
l'herbe sous le pied le temps me disait
toujours que quand elle voyait là
d'abraham au travers des rivières
c'était la pluie avant trois jours tout
à l'heure que vous allez voir le soleil
se coucher vous n'avez qu'à regarder
dans les fenêtres si c'est rouge la
dalle est dans les maisons comme il y
aura des fers dans nos maisons quand il
se couche alors on essaie d'avoir du
beau temps on le sait les roses le soir
par exemple qu'il fera devant le
lendemain dans mon petit chien se
grattent les oreilles c'est qu'il va
plus vers le lendemain on y parle comme
si l'air
dans sa lettre m agent il fait un très
mauvais quand les vaches qu'on l'accord
les tu vas faire de l'orage
[Musique]